- So cool.
Rocking and rolling.
Where'd Frank go?
(SHOUTING) Frank?
I'm looking around.
Frank.
Find anything?
Mike.
What?
Oilzum?
- We got Oilzum.
- I don't know.
A whole case?
Killer.
MIKE (VOICEOVER): Hands down,
Frank is the oil can guy.
Oil can central.
MIKE (VOICEOVER):
That's what he collects.
That's what he loves the most.
But he knows that
I'm the Oilzum guy.
I love Oilzum.
I always have.
I love the logo.
I love the history
of the company.
I love the color.
Hell, I even like
the way it smells.
Empty.
FRANK: That doesn't look so hot.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my goodness.
It's in there.
You got something
to pop it open?
- Yeah.
- Uh oh.
Frank's got it.
What do you got?
Oh yeah, baby.
Look at that.
Oh, yeah.
- Oh.
- Oh, yeah.
This is it.
Oh, yeah.
Oilzum was one of the first
brand-name motor oils.
From the quality
of their product,
to their marketing genius,
and their connection
to America's racing history,
and then on top of that,
that incredible logo,
you cannot think
gas and oil without Oilzum.
It's that iconic.
- Oh, yeah.
You got it.
Oh, yeah.
See, Jay?
- See, Jay?
A little patience.
This end's open.
Right there.
Come on.
Oh, baby, there we go.
Now, here, let me
do it over here.
Here, you got it?
You got it?
Yeah.
Want me to hold
the light on it?
- Yeah, go ahead.
- Yeah.
Get that.
- Surgery?
You gotta get it.
- It's gonna crack right there.
- I know.
That's what I'm saying.
There it comes.
I'm getting it.
Yeah, that's it.
- Ah.
- There, now you can.
- There it is.
- All right.
- Now you can get the can out.
- Are you ready?
I'm ready.
All right, Frank,
hold the light.
- This is it.
And--
Whoa.
- Oh.
- Ah.
Ah, this paper label.
Oh.
Paper.
Ugh, paper.
But underneath the
paper, it looks like--
- I know.
- You know?
I know.
MIKE (VOICEOVER):
You can find the box.
And you can find the can.
But to find the can in
the box with the paper
label on it that's never been
opened before is super rare.
And it says "high pressure,
superheated steam cylinder
oil."
- Wow.
You know what that's for?
Locomobiles.
That's exactly what it's
for is steam engines.
Steam engines.
As soon as I saw the
can, I said something.
I said an expletive to myself,
meaning that now, Jay-- for god
sakes, now, you know, it's
time to stand up or sit down.
That's a great can.
[sighing]
It was good.
And that's what the problem was.
It was almost too good to sell.
I wish I had another one.
You didn't even
know you had that one.
I know I didn't.
I would know eventually.
400 and-- 400, and it's gone.
I'll even put the
cover back on for you.
- Where's my 10%?
- All right.
We're doing it.
MIKE (VOICEOVER): It's great
that it's in the box instead
of just a can on a shelf.
Because, you know, just to
show it to somebody and go,
look at this Oilzum can in
the box, is a mind bender.
Could you say ah for a minute?
Ah.
Oh, that's for pulling my tooth?
Exactly.
This is 1880.
And the way this
works-- it was patented.
As you squeeze--
- It would cut your tooth off?
No.
As you squeeze the handle, the
first thing it does, it grabs--
It grabs the tooth?
It grabs the tooth
beside the bad tooth.
And then as you grab
a little further--
Ew.
--it pushes the
other tooth out.
FRANK (VOICEOVER): I mean, this
is one of those things where
they say, no pain, no gain.
And what would something
like this go for?
Uh, $20.
You got a deal.
I'll never see
another one like it.
I don't think you will either.
After you leave this house,
you will never see another one.
Can we look in here?
Yep, sure.
These two boxes, these
are things that we've
decided that we don't need.
They're not part of
the core collection.
And if you want to take them
and put them on the table
and take a look--
- Let's see.
Yeah, let's take a quick look.
Oh, boy.
FRANK (VOICEOVER): Jay
says that this isn't
part of the core collection.
But I'm getting a little nervous
there's price tags on them.
The tags are on here because
this has been inventoried.
We have a clock
person that's come
and looked at all our clocks.
- OK.
- So the tag has a retail price.
- All right.
These would mount
on the dash of a car.
This one I really like.
I mean, look at the mount.
The mount's right
there, goes right up.
It's kind of looking
right at you.
You don't have to take your
eyes off the road too much.
Got a few little pocket watches.
- Yep.
- Got some emblems here.
- Yes.
FRANK (VOICEOVER): He's
got three head badges.
And these would go on the
front grille of a car.
These are great
collectible items.
FRANK: Yeah, just these six
pieces here, how about 650?
Ah, that's a-- that's
a little low, 650.
And I was probably
more like, do you
wanna split the difference
between 8 and 650?
I'll do it.
7 and a quarter.